this is a perfect opportunity you guys
want to take their spots you guys want
to play with the 19's yes
so this is the time that you show that
you guys deserve to take the spots of
those guys
so you have to be organized from start
to finish but it has to be together
right there's got to be clear indication
of what you guys want
you guys understand
[Music]
after six months of quarantine the
sporting kansas city academy has finally
returned to the field
the entire club is adjusting to new
protocols and taking extra precautions
to keep everyone safe and help
but excitement is running high and
opportunities are on the line as coaches
see which players have come prepared
and are ready to take their game to the
next level
uh we gotta wear a mask when we when we
walk in and we always have to take uh
the temperature you know and
yeah they make us fill up some
some form some nightly forms just hey
what's up
ask about how you feel if you feel sick
or any of that
just to be sure i think it's
it's necessary you know they're trying
to keep us safe and you know i follow
the rules so
i respect it things that have have
changed are
because of the social distancing the
players don't have access to
all the resources within the facility
you know and so
they can't come in and make shakes after
practice um
they don't get to use all of the you
know the locker rooms or
you you get taped up at the field and
then you know
after practice you have to leave you
have to bring your own water before that
everything was provided now that the
players returned from quara team
there's definitely a different
excitement because i think players
realize
that you're not always guaranteed reps
and you're not
guaranteed games and training when that
was taken away
i think it shocked a lot of the kids
system i think
we have now seen how
hungry the players are to be involved
in our academy you're going to find out
what these kids are made of who wants to
be a real pro
when they come back tracking it down but
he can't get there in time jake davis
chance here for swope park i've been
working for
a professional contract for about two
and a half years
i signed it during quarantine if you're
training with them every week
um i think when you actually do make
that jump as a professional
you know i don't think it would be that
hard i think it's just more about
mentality
we uh just not have a nine o'clock uh
training
saturday and we were just scrimmage
today you're always you're always
fighting for a spot so
you always feel the pressure even if
it's an inner squad against each other
i feel a pressure like everybody trying
to take each other's spots you know you
never know
which one's gonna be your last scrimmage
i don't really get butterflies for
scrimmages
or games that matter i just
know i got i just know what i got to do
and keep focused
and uh prove to the coaches that
i belong on this team and belong on the
to get a starting spot five six
seven eight nine ten
you know everybody should try to have a
spot for to play
so everybody's just out here you know
locked in
try to get some minute in the game so
everybody just go hard even before
practice
as soon as we step in the field you know
focused on you know
play soccer and everything um you know
obviously we're all we're all chasing
the same dream here you know everyone
here is you know we're all competitive
but
at the end of the day you know we're all
teammates we're all brothers so we treat
everyone with respect and you know
everyone knows that here
um the first training session um i think
um
we're a bit like mentally um you know
not there because you know we've been
away for so long but you know after a
few
minutes you know a few plays i think we
all just clicked and got together
fast ozzy is uh he look he's a special
player and
we feel like he has got all the tools to
be become
a pro and to become one of our next
homegrown players
growing up on my brothers they brought
me into playing soccer
i always played up with them and i think
playing with them
playing with other kids it's kind of
prepared me you know
kind of like playing here my house fly
me um i've been on them since i was
like around six or seven so when they
gave me the opportunity um it was
it was easy for me and my parents
because you know we trust each other and
i just think
we have a good relationship and it just
made the transition a lot easier
um
obviously moving in with another family
it's different but
they treated me as as as their own as
their kid as their son so
i'm truly grateful for them and will
always be thankful
it was tough at first it's a totally new
environment especially
moving away from your family being in a
whole different type of routine
i think it's important to get to know
your host family
have a really open mind you know they
want to feel
like they're valued i think when they're
a family too
they're letting you stay with them you
got to be really respectful and
um i think it's also being you know
involved and
invested in having a good relationship
with them the host family
program it's extremely crucial to their
development we've also used the money
that audi has
provided us to advertise for host
families
we have a person that is
fully dedicated uh her name is betsy
maxfield she's our director of player
care
she goes out and she vets the the
families we do background checks on them
uh she does the house inspections um and
so she's done a phenomenal job
in regards to helping us find the host
families and it's it's not an easy thing
the host families are
uh massive to our uh the development of
our players
so today that's what we're gonna do
we're going to split into three teams
right black is going to be
mono kobe jack lucas david this team is
in yellow
alex brax danny gutierrez
nico clinton jack dean natty
zaire dylan hey
make sure everything is quality all the
technical stuff
what the scrimmage is is um it's this is
competition for for places i think we do
a really good job in
promoting the younger players to be put
in a
situation where they are being
challenged
constantly and are uncomfortable
i've been watching them the 15s and
the 17-19 is playing i actually got a
little injury um
talked to the athletic trainers and you
know we just thought it was best if i
would
take um take a little break you know
don't want to risk um
getting a greater injury than this
obviously it's frustrating you know
i want to be out there working hard you
know trying to get better every day and
you know
obviously injuries are part of the game
and you just got to deal with them
ozzy said he felt some like a little bit
of
of tension or uncomfortableness in his
groin ozzy will
probably end up playing a lot so it's
just managing him because he's going to
be pushed
physically playing with kids who are a
lot bigger than him and a lot older than
him this year
yeah yeah it's gotta be passed through
and you gotta find it good defending uh
we just competed and tried to
win every single battle to tackle we
could and uh we talked to each other
communicated on defense and on offense
and
uh know where each other was going
before we even played each other the
ball
and yeah we were in stick with each
other there was a lot of lack of
communication and focus so we kind of
messed up
on my team but i mean everybody is here
to become pro so
obviously everybody is really good so
it's just
who won it bad you know just
focus everybody has to be focused i
think
over the course of the quarantine i
think you got to see
which players were committed which
players weren't because
you know they didn't have coaches every
day yelling and pushing you have to have
that commitment you have to have that
engagement
and you have to be able to execute
because you never know what's going to
happen
you know you never know when these
opportunities are going to be taken from
you again
i'm very proud of to be part of this big
club you know
one of my main goals that i've always
had is i want to
be able to compete against the best guys
in the world and hopefully i get to
achieve that someday
one step at a time right one step at a
time
with players back in action at sporting
kc and across mls
the stakes have never been higher every
moment on the field is an opportunity to
make a statement
can gauge natty and ozzy ascend to the
next level or will someone else emerge
to take their spot
next time on the academy we'll see who
rises to the challenge as rivals come to
town
and competitive action returns